la la la you ready big guy yeah I'm like
totally ready everyone in the city gets
a shot at being a storm in our thinking
competition
this stage is about to explode with
major biggie pow
no Humpty you're really funny looking
that's all right cause I get things
cooking come on Lady
come come my lady you're my butterfly
sugar baby oh my gosh look at her butt
oh my gosh look at her are you okay oh
yes I'm fine thank you how are you if
you want to become stars and win a
hundred grand and you better be ready to
work harder than you've ever worked in
your lives
oh yes that was dearie bed we're strong
there's no Hill where were you I was a
rehearsal dad I don't want to be in your
game I want to be a singer how did I end
up with a son not you music in all
things and talk to you I can sing but
scared come on be confident don't you
want this I'm back what is going on here
the moment try the fries and only
squeeze it in holding we consider these
minutes go don't let fear stop you from
doing the thing you love you know what's
great about hitting rock bottom there's
only one way left to go and that's
[Music]
this my son
she's not even that good yeah yeah
totally
[Music]
just see
the
I'm sorry uh
[Applause]
you
[Music]
why aren't you rehearsing I'm through
they said I'm an intolerable egomaniac I
don't even know what that means
[Music]
you